ça va
alors ce que les gens sympas c'est un
peu comme les bd avec des danses voici
pays c'est plein de choses non mais
beigbeder on le voit ici tu vois un pari
faire le pitre et tout mais en fait il
vend des livres dans le monde entier et
toi c'est un peu pareil parce que
ya rayah c'est un carton mondial rock
the casbah aussi je fais des concerts
dans le monde entier c'est quoi elle est
même pas énorme il est youtube ouais
c'est tout ouais tout mais c'est vrai
nom
là tu vas à saint-pétersbourg au mois de
mai est et en amérique sans arrêt dans
ce cas intéressant moscou saint
pétersbourg je travaille bahreïn et new
way et qui est que non c'est drôle parce
que c'est une histoire bon en fait que
je voulais ça fait 20 ans voulait bosser
on sent bien un jour se rencontrer deux
un concert où il tire avec robin wright
et robert plant tous ces gens là et me
dit tu y as marre il ya une chanson que
tu as fait et je voulais à faire il ya
très très longtemps je dis ah bon et
c'était à bina effet une version
anglaise en a chanté ensemble et après
donc on a eu des provisions pour faire
des concerts dans le monde ouais et en
fait donc de deux concerts à moscou
saint pétersbourg avait pas aller nous
tout le monde ne soit enfin ceux qui
connaissent pas part à m le producteur
de youtou way
to un des fondateurs de roxy music bien
sûr il ya des trucs que les gens savent
pas aussi c'est que tu as fait une
chanson sur l'album de carlos santana
qui s'appelle supernatural qui s'est
vendu à 28 millions d'exemplaires sont
et qui s'appelle migra
avait repris une chanson qui s'appelait
quel mac il a repris la chanson est
agité la seule star à sherbrooke arabe
rock tout court rock tout court si tu es
arabe rachid ans c'est pas la peine de
te remets les yeux
ça représente quand même 500 millions de
personnes tu as raison et puis en plus
toi tu détestes cette idée de communauté
un sas est seigneur tu dis si on
maintient pas cette différence avec les
pays anglo saxons des fous tu rêves dans
la merde ouais le communautarisme tu
penses l'était ce sens un peu comme une
caresse tout ça où les religions tout je
pense que qui a il faut avoir parce que
je regarde les émissions par foyer vous
savez on parle beaucoup de religions en
ce moment l'islam le judaïsme le
catholicisme et c'est sur ça lamentable
parce que la plupart des gens il en
parle très très mal il ya une chose
qu'ils oublient c'est parler du coeur
toi tu es un laïc musulman tu dis non
c'est bon le second rang internet
et les cuisines dit ceci étant l'islam
tu dis c'est pas mal parce que c'est
comme une religion qui qui autorise et
qui permet de faire l'amour alors que
les cathos à ses côtés au péché non il
ya mille manières veut dire je t'aime
honorable obtenir que le prophète parle
beaucoup de sexe ouais mais beaucoup
d'amour il y avait beaucoup il y avait
d'ailleurs est un proverbe qui dit dans
un et versets du coran il y ait rien ne
vaut le deauville femmes élevant d'un
homme ouais donc à chaque canal cette
religion
d'identité quand il ya au dessus des
routes et y'a des trucs
bonne et moi au courant doit encore way
or ceci étant tu diras schiste c'est
difficile d'être musulman quand on voit
l'absence de démocratie dans l'est dans
les pays arabes et surtout quand
l'égypte enferme des homosexuels au nom
de l'islam quoi ouais j'ai dit ça
d'ailleurs donc ce qui est étonnant
c'est qu'il ya une chose qui est en
train de changer là par exemple dans mon
dernier album si tutu ou jeu bonjour je
suis assez cru où je veux lui dit
qu'elle manque démocratie dans les pays
arabes je suis qu'à bon c'est
complètement radical et quand j'ai joué
à la main dernièrement où il y avait des
gens qui rêvent qui chantait avec moi 1
c'est la première fois où des gens
disaient il faut les il faut les comment
dirais-je les les emprisonner des lits
et puis leur demander des comptes
c'était la première fois ça se passe et
donc à une espèce de des libertés vous
savez pourquoi je vais vous dire une
chose parce que bon aussi con que ça
puisse paraître en irak malgré le le le
ce qui se passe mal qu'elle à
l'occupation américaine et où les gens
ont voté à anbar estiment ils ont voté
donc ces images se passe dans les pays
arabes est donc le peuple arabe ils sont
là il se dit merde ils votent pourquoi
on voterait pas ouais donc et donc à une
espèce de d2d réponse à jean la
démocratie exactement une cotation et ça
c'est lui qui avait raison finalement
alors ben c'est marrant mais ouais mais
quelque part je dis chiche à rendriez
ababou 3,70 en écoute c'est très rare
non mais c'est très très rare ici que
fait chier mais je dis bon que sharon
est critiquée à l'époque de sabra et
chatila mais même maintenant comme
des guides ou comme rabin c'est des gens
qui étaient des faucons qui étaient des
vrais militaires c'est eux qui ont fait
la paix et charolles je pense quelque
part c'est la paix en train de se
dessiner en palestine et c'est ça qui
est intéressant est ce que je voudrais
dire aux gens rebuts sont la part des
palestiniens ouais qui nous connaissent
absolument rien parce que je leur dis
n'est pas destiné à une chose ils ne
sont pas antisémites gay ils ne sont
absolument pas audi ces mythes et des
juifs c'est des frères ok donc qu'on
arrête discours les juifs c'est des
connards des officiels de pouvoir des
urnes dernièrement je suis une interview
et que une journaliste égyptienne et me
dit un parent d'israël jeudi vont
évidemment vous allez me dire des
conneries vous savez vous chanter sur
aïcha
sacralisé tout c'est injuste qu'il a
fait ouais du havre c'est jean jacques
goldman
gabon c'est un juif diddy ces doses qui
a produit ces ajuste danos de voisenon
toise d abord j alors arrêtez c'est
grâce aux juifs ou danser et d'ailleurs
si je suis là c'est grâce à jules
s'appelle alain lalanne a bougé tourner
dans les pays arabes alors s'il vous
plaît il ya une chose est de même dans
les pays comme la france démocratique et
il y ait deux personnes qui seront
absolument importante pour moi c'est
simone veil pour l'avortement que
monsieur badinter pour la a besoin de la
peine de mort c'est des juifs et moins
dé france voilà donc c'est pour ça je
voulais leur dire ça
c'est c'est assez rare d'entendre ce
genre de discours
de quelqu'un de faim rebeu quoi c'est à
dire que c'est c'est dangereux de
banlieue pour lui et il le dit pas
seulement ici à la télé il est quand
même
quand il va non mais ça c'est ce que je
suis sonné quand il va en jordanie il
tient ce genre de discours s'est passé
anti démago extrêmement risquée et il
dit
il dit des choses faisons la paix mais
il dit aussi arrêter vos conneries et
c'est la musique est merveilleux se
passera plus lui il a vraiment quelque
chose
qui est de toute manière contagieux
qu'on comprenne pour une maladie ou pour
un truc positif c'est une et résistible
envie de danser de faire la fête et
d'embrasser son voisin quand on voit son
spectacle peu importe la couleur de peau
et les voilà si les cheveux frisés ou
pas et ça c'est une avancée incroyable
quoi ça ça va ça va partout et ça va ça
va pour rien
le sport
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
dinars 10 tubes abonnez vous je m'étais
un peu ce bleu